one of the proudest moments in Oscars
history was that night in 1946 when
Harold Russell won two awards for the
best years of our lives
he speaks tonight for millions of
special people as he presents the award
for outstanding achievement in visual
effects and by aside one of mother
nature's most remarkable visual effects
Farrah Fawcett
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm very happy to be here tonight so
proud to have this lovely and wonderful
lady by my side delighted to present
tonight the nominees for outstanding
achievement in visual effects and they
are H R Giger collar embody Brian
Johnson Nick Calder and Dennis saving
for alien
Peter Ellen Shaw art crew shank used to
slice at Danny Lee Harrison Ellen Shaw
and Joe Hale for the black hole
Derrick nettings Paul Wilson and John
Evans for moan raka
William a Fraker ad flowers and Gregory
gene for 1941 let's Trumbo John price go
Richard yours and Robert swath Dave
Stewart and Grant MacEwan for Star Trek
and the winner is thank you very much
the winners are H R Giger Carlo Rambaldi
Rian Johnson
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
three years ago when I was here for King
Kong
I don't know English and they'd say
thank you now I learn very well English
and they say thank you very much
I'm very happy to help this thank you
very much thank Ridley Scott for his
amazing direction of this movie and
without his effort we wouldn't be here
tonight and I'd like to thank our crew
England boy they really went for it and
they got it thanks very much
[Applause]
[Music]
for those of you at home I forgot to
mention there's an English simulcast on
96.4